Here we go.
Hello, everybody. I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters. We have a number of questions to get through this Zoom call. So let's get at it right away.
So dealing with weight loss issues, you see organ concentrations in supplements.
We'll explain that what are tumor-associated macrophages.
Changes in your stool, traveling with the right and wound care are the questions that are received.
Again, try to get your questions there early if you can so we can get them into this, or you can ask them when or online.
But again, well, you're muted. Make sure you unmute yourself if you have a question as we get through this.
So the first question about dealing with weight loss. How do you deal with weight loss?
So weight loss, uncontrolled weight loss with cancers called kickexia.
So uncontrolled weight loss with cancer is called wasting syndrome or kickexia.
That's typically, if you're losing two to four pounds a week and you're not had changed your diet, you're not trying to lose weight.
You're at a state where you're well below your normal weight, your desired weight.
And you can't seem to put the brakes on that weight loss.
What are there things to do?
No, I did share a whole video and blog post on this so do search for that on our blog as well.
But just briefly, some of the things that would be beneficial is marijuana.
So marijuana can be really beneficial using medical marijuana in a case of kickexia.
Why? Because one of the things that marijuana does using it as an edible or even smoking marijuana can cause a person to have an increased appetite.
So medical marijuana, the side effect that can increase the person's appetite can give the person the munchies that has been known to say.
And getting an increase in appetite is hard because usually with kickexia, it's not that the person is eating 3,000 calories a day and can't is still losing weight.
They have other issues that are going are going out there.
They're nauseous.
They're not feeling well, they're having a plate put in front of them of a meal and they're able to eat a few bites.
They just can't feel like they're eating it can't eat anymore.
Well, using marijuana can decrease nausea can increase appetite and decrease pain can increase rest.
So it can increase the depth of sleep that you're getting.
So that can give a person more energy by using medical marijuana. So it has some benefits there.
And then also doing some exercise even if you're confined to bed, getting some 5 pound weights and doing some arm curls.
If you can stand up doing some squats, stimulating large muscle groups is very beneficial with kickexia because if you're stimulating large muscle groups by doing arm curls, if you can curl 10 pounds or 15 pounds or 20 pounds.
So it's very beneficial.
You're calling on the need for glucose in the muscles to make ATP to make energy to use the muscles.
It steals ATP, it steals energy, it steals glucose away from the cancer.
It can be very beneficial to help with muscle waste team syndrome.
So if you're at a place where you could get IV vitamin C, you could also get IV nutrition, IV vitamins, that can be helpful.
Even IV fluids can be helpful in these cases.
Drinking protein shakes, but again, most people that are in a state of cookie are like, yeah, I made a protein shake for my husband, but he'll only drink a few sips of it and he just won't drink anymore.
I don't know where one has its benefits because we can increase that appetite.
So do go back and watch the video on the blog for more information that I could be helpful.
Next question.
What's your take on using bovine organ concentrate?
So bovine organ, organ concentrate is an organ tissue.
So organ tissue became very common use a nutraceutical back in the 1960s, really, maybe even before that some companies came out with it.
I know biotics research and standard process where the two companies that really started using organ concentrates, they can be extremely beneficial.
So one of the belief systems with organ concentrates is that when an organ is, let's say, hurting.
So let's say your thymus gland needs help to keep up to one of your things that your thymus gland does is it helps stimulate immune function.
The thymus gland may need help in keeping up with the immune response, let's say your thymus gland actually secrete message your RNA.
Well, a lot to be heard about message your RNA this last year with these vaccinations.
Well, message your RNA is made by your body.
So we're not talking about a message your RNA drug that's called a vaccine that's projected in you to do bad things to yourselves.
Your your healthy cells release message your RNA to tag something that will be helpful for that cell.
So message your RNA travels to your broadened gland.
It's released in your saliva and what you are exposed to any nutrient that's going to help that organ message that message your RNA tags that nutrients from the saliva is it travels down to your stomach.
Tags it as you absorb it and it will help bring it to that organ to help that organ heal.
The other benefit of glandulars is that a person has an autoimmune attack on a certain gland.
Let's say they have an autoimmune attack on the thyroid by you taking thyroid glandulars.
You're actually the autoimmune attack is happening partly on that organ glandular that you're consuming and on the thyroid itself so can help calm down in an autoimmune attack.
But we're not treated autoimmune disease here. We're treating cancer so can organ glandulars be beneficial for a cancer.
Let's say if a person has ovarian cancer, can taking this product like cytosolium, happy beneficial where it has an ovary tissue in it.
I did write a blog post about this several years ago using organ glandulars for cancer.
There's a lot of there's several studies that are out there and there's a lot of theory that's out there that it can be beneficial by using the glandular of the tissue that you have the cancer.
You have the cancer with that it can help the body respond better and help that tissue heal better so has it been proven out with our testing not always we do use these products.
I like biotics who search glandulars especially because they're all all their gladiulars also have a superoxide dismutase and caneles with it which are really strong into accidents they help protect the glandular for many years beyond the expiration date but they also help protect the glandular substance when it's brought into the body.
And if it is brought to the tissue site especially for cancer cells let's say if I have cancer in my ovaries and I'm taking ovarian tissue here the site is I have then it's going to be brought there with the SOD and caneles so you have that antioxidant benefit that you're that you're carrying directly to the cancer itself so I'm a big fan of using
glandulars now the argument that people say as well this is mobile tissue that I'm supposed to be off of meat don't you don't need to worry about this is this organ tissue and this is not muscle tissue of the of the cow so mobile means cow this is also taken from organically grown cows now they're still exposed to chemicals no matter what you do but they're as clean as you can get.
So biotic researchers has a very strong reputation with their gladiulars and they're a company that I trust a lot they've been doing this for many many years so bovine organic gladiulars are great the problem is is they don't have them for everything standard or biotics has the greatest array of them in their stock but they don't have for every single tissue but they have
maybe more 15 different tissue gladiulars so they can be very beneficial typically from a functional medicine standpoint gladiulars are used to help stimulate that organ using thyroid gladiulars can be very helpful with a person with hypothyroidism using adrenal gladiulars can be very helpful for somebody who has you know dealing with stress issues dealing with low thyroid issues.
This product is thigh this doesn't stand for thigh right this stands for thymus so this would be an immune stimulator this cytosine thigh and the f stands for female here and that has ovary has to a terry has hypothelmas ovary and I think uterine tissue in there but that's a great balance formula for women.
So gladiulars can be great tissues things to add to their product line.
Here's a question what are TAMs I think the person who asked this question watch to my video on TAMs these are tissue associated tumor associated macrophages so just briefly you can go to the blog post and
search for tumor associated macrophages and you'll see a 20 minute video on this but real briefly is that there's been numerous studies that show that cancers typically hard cancers can pull in macrophages so macrophages are part of your white blood cell system that is supposed to fight cancers and help kill cancers.
Well tumors can basically recruit macrophages and make them work for the tumor and they can assist the tumor in increasing blood supply to the tumor they can assist the tumor to fight other T cells that are in natural killer cells that are trying to kill the cancer.
So these macrophages basically go to the dark side if you want to say it that way and it's it's through different chemical reactions through the process of the tumor utilizing Vegeph which is vascular endothelial growth factor and through hypoxic conditions so conditions of decreased oxygen.
So that's why one of the reasons one of the small reasons why we don't want our cancer patients wearing masks because any state of hypoxia is going to increase the formation of tumor associated macrophages which are called M2 macrophages it's another name for macrophages that have been recruited by a cancer to work for the cancer and work against the immune system.
These tumor associated M2 macrophages spit out all these cytokines these nasty inflammatory cytokines down here in the right side of this yellow moxed out here IL4 IL13 IL6 highly inflammatory chemicals that then block the immune response and that's not a good thing.
And in the video if you go to that blog post and watch the video it's there are some very specific things that a person can do that you many of our patients are already doing using green txtrack resveratrol using curcumin any of the anti inflammatory flavonoids using immune stimulants which all of our patients are doing will help them.
Block the formation of these M2 tumor associated macrophages so it'll keep the macrophages in this M1 state it'll help deliver macrophages in the M1 state they're the good guys they're the ones helping kill the cancer this M1 state macrophages will help kill cancer and will and if you continue on.
Those type of products those type of nutrition the interest in the study is the studies have been done to their proving that this is taking place and then they're trying to find pharmaceutical drugs that they're trying to create pharmaceutical drugs that will block this push from M1 state good guys to the M2 state bad guys the tumor associated macrophages from taking place.
But we already have it are arsenal all these specific nutritional products that block that that block hypoxia that block these other pathways these HDAC3 pathways that will help stimulate these and block these cc and three PGE2 CCL2 these other pathways we already have it are arsenal things that will block the pathways from moving M1 to M2.
They will stimulate moving M2 back to M1 pushing the bad guys back to the good guys and will block the production of all these bad inflammatory cytokines down in the yellow box on the right hand side.
So most of our patients are taking things that will already do this if you want more information you can watch that more lengthy video where I go into detail on those products.
Those are tumor associated macrophages just another reason why you know why is my immune system not killing the cancer the cancer so smart it's recruiting the guys that are supposed to come and kill it to be its friend and work on its behalf kind of like our political system today.
So you can do it that way that you can understand to move associated macrophages.
Next question by stools have been hard these past couple weeks which is abnormal for me I still have in 2 to 3 all moments per day but I'm having a lot of gas which is very embarrassing any advice.
So whatever you're having hard stools the first thing you think of is are you drinking enough water because if you're dehydrated you can have hard stools.
Digestive enzymes and hydrochloric acid are another first thing you think of so the other thing that will help pull water into the bowel is magnesium.
So the reason why a person takes magnesium and has looser stools is because you have a need for magnesium in your body that in fact probably of any other nutrient there is magnesium is utilized in more metabolic pathways than anything else.
However, any excess magnesium will just be dumped back into the colon that magnesium because it's a positive ion will draw water to it so if you take more magnesium than you need.
Then you will dump it into the colon it draws water and you will loosen your stools so one of the easiest way if you have real difficult.
Stools you have hard stools constipation by first go to is add magnesium start taking some magnesium before bed you'll usually have looser stools just because it'll draw water but you can't be dehydrated either so make sure you're drinking enough water also.
You can have hard stools and especially this last hint about lots of gas because you're not getting proper digestion so if you're getting a lot of gas you're getting food that's sitting in your colon and your small intestine longer than it should it's fermented and then fermentation is causing gas so different foods will ferment quickly that's why eating beans or something like that are gassy foods quote unquote because they ferment quickly.
So you have to ask yourself what's your diet like I'm eating a lot of these foods that ferment or as food just stated my colon longer we may have a longer intestine of transit time therefore it's has more time to ferment and I'm not getting enough digestive enzymes and so adding digestive enzymes added HCl hydrochloric acid with each meal when you eat your food is when you take.
The HCl you can take digestive enzymes right then too much take digestive enzymes anytime make sure you have enough water consumption and then make sure you add magnesium so those are the things that I would suggest for that issue next question do I need to take my right on the plate and carry on or can I check it through to my destination i've done both.
So you can take it with what you want to care as a carry on if you don't trust how you know if you have a real small bag that you're that you're checking and you don't trust how it's thrown around it's pretty hardy if you're rapid and a sweatshirt or something like that and then.
and then stuff it between your clothes it's it's you're not going to have really probably any issues in the breaking the bulb is certainly not going to break there's times that I did not have a check luggage so I just brought it as a carry on as well often you get it gets beeped and they look at you and ask questions on you know what is this thing and I try to explain it to you then they look cross eye to you and.
to hand it over to back to you so they could tell by the scan that there wasn't a bomb or something as they x-rated but sometimes out of curiosity they've asked me what it is sometimes they never even asked me what it was at all so.
Either way whatever's more convenient for you we've had you know we have people you know travel home with their right all the time we've never ever to this point had an issue with it.
Next question because this tumor is continuing to trade this is not a picture of the patient's tumor I just pulled it off the internet is continuing to trade do I need to stay out of the ocean out of pools or out of hot tons.
If you have an open wood you really should never go in a hot tub and get that open wood wet so it was in your foot it'd be pretty hard to stay out of the hot tub if you're if you have an open wood on your foot.
As far as a pool I would still be careful not to get it wet you don't want to introduce infection to an open wood that's the whole point you know if you're going to go in the ocean oh it's salt water it's going to sting it's not going to be clean it's going to contain all sorts of particles yeah I would not let an open wood get wet or I would try to prevent now I put pulled up this picture because there's different causes that you could use.
This is obviously just a piece of the gauze that will absorb fluid and it's put on with tape this would not be a good piece of gauze to put on going into try to keep an open wood wet dry but there are plastic eyes to gauze with tape on the outside that you could easily put over an open wood.
How big the wood is and where it is just to prevent that you want to go under water with it but that it would keep it protected should water splash on it so I wouldn't you know if you have a wood on your breast and you want to go in the water up to your belly button or a little bit higher and you're not going to splash around or something I would I would for sure do that can be very therapeutic but I'd be careful I would be careful not to get it wet.